SMP Westminster leader in Blackford I
mean I was quite struck by Mark Carper
not really being able to spell out a
route to a referendum what did you make
of the interview well that's quite
extraordinary Ruby because we were told
that this is a partnership with equals
it's a union of equals and of course if
you have such a union you need to have
consent Mark Harper talks about the
Prime Minister working with the Scottish
government look we want to work when
it's right with the UK government we
work together on Ukraine for example we
all Stand Together
but there has to be a respect for
democracy and but you know Mark Harper
talks about 2014 of what happened what
he admitted to see was that after that
referendum all parties came together
under the Smith commission there was an
agreement about more prayers for the
Scottish Parliament crucially every
party signed up in that document to
another referendum if the people of
Scotland chose to have one what happened
in 2021 is that we had an election to
the Scottish Parliament now we have two
votes there's the constituency msps and
there's less for us look at the way that
Westminster does that look at the
constituency msps we won the vast
majority of the seats to that Parliament
63 out of 73 there is a Independence
majority in that Parliament you know
when the government is in power it's
imperative enact its Manifesto and
there's a Manifesto commitment from
ourselves and our partners in the greens
of delivering an independence referendum
in the second half of the Scottish
Parliament it is not a good loot for
Westminster to say we don't hear you
we're going to ignore you you can't
continue to ignore democracy we know
that the root for the Scottish
Parliament calling its own referendum is
not one that's viable after the court
action today and we respect the decision
of the of the Supreme Court but again
that's Westminster that has legislated
through the Scotland act to stop the
Scottish Parliament going down such a
route there has to be a way in that
scenario that the Scottish Parliament
the Scottish government can trigger a
referendum and of course in the previous
referendum we had the Edinburgh
agreement that was an agreement of the
two governments that that referendum
could take place Westminster can't just
hope this goes away it won't go away so
what is your next step then you say you
respect the Supreme Court decision my
message to the prime minister is is
recognize the reality of that mandate
that the Scottish Parliament the
Scottish government has we should have
talks that allows the Scottish
government to have a section 30
Authority that we can have that
referendum now I if we don't have that I
would regret that position but that then
means what the first Minister said that
the the next selection that we're going
to face as a Westminster one the only
option that we would have the only
realistic option option for now would be
to use that general election as a de
facto campaign for a Scottish reference
is there a problem though because what
you're doing there is you're saying that
people are voting in an election as if
it's a referendum but of course the
people vote in elections for all kinds
of different things we look at the
living standards issue that people are
now facing look at the NHS look at
schools look at Energy prices people can
vote for all kinds of different reasons
you can't just say they're definitely
just voting well on a binary issue we're
of course going to have a conference in
the early part of next year and we'll
debate all these things and we'll come
to a very firm conclusion about how
we're going to face this but we're in a
situation that Westminster is not
recognizing the harsh reality of a
government in Edinburgh that has that
mandate so if we have to look at
mechanisms such as using Innovation and
then we would have to appeal to the
people of Scotland to recognize that
this is a one-off this is about making
sure that Westminster does listen to the
voices of the people of Scotland and of
course we're setting a high bar because
we have to win that election and win it
with more than 50 percent of the the
vote actually it's interesting if you
look at the 2021 Scottish election and
the list votes slightly more than 50
percent of the voters voted for
independent supporting parties so we
will take that challenge if we have to
but of course when we have that debate
it's about what kind of country it's
about how you respond to that cost of
living crisis it's about how you deliver
sustainable economic growth you say um
that it would be a one-off I mean that's
what we were told last time wasn't it
with the last Independence referendum
one of the points if you look at the two
the two agreements the Edinburgh
agreement and the Smith commission at
the end of it there was nothing in
either of these documents that said that
this was a a once in a lifetime
opportunity but oh that's all sort of
member
you know you you go through the
documents I know you're across all the
detail but for many people they'll think
look you've already had a different
Independence referendum why'd you want
another one two things have happened
Sophia since then one is that we were
told in 2014 if we stayed in the UK that
we'd be staying in the European Union
and that's real makes it harder in some
ways doesn't it for an independent
Scotland you'd be talking about a hard
border potentially with past foot
control with Customs checks we know that
people in the EU so that you're going to
have to adopt the Euro if you want to
become a member we can go through these
things one at a time but the point is
that if you look at polling and Scotland
72 percent of people in Scotland want to
be back in the European Union
Independence creates an opportunity for
us to do that the opportunities that we
have for trade and investment as a
consequence of coming back in the
European Union it's about making sure
that we can deliver the economy that we
know that the people in Scotland look we
have seen a declining population on a
relative basis with the United Kingdom
for every decade for the last 150 years
we have to change the record I know
through green energy for example people
we can upscale our production five-fold
we can deliver 385 000 jobs in energy as
a consequence of doing this we have a
plan for delivering growth for
delivering prosperity of delivering on
our climate climate targets and we need
the powers of Independence to do that
why for example Westminster is holding
us back in carbon capture and storage
there are many examples I mean the
things that we would do that would
transform the Scottish economy now you
talk about trade and so on take Ireland
as an example you go back to the
post-war period more than 80 percent of
Ireland's trade was with the UK it's now
nine percent because they've grown the
overseas markets and actually over that
period And every year iron's trade with
the UK has grown there is a growth
opportunity that we will deliver on
delivering Prosperity driving down on
the poverty that we're inherenting from
the current regime it's a message of
Hope and we will do this we will win
this argument I think tonight there's a
lot of people in Scotland have a resolve
that we will not be silent and not be
stopped by the UK government not
recognizing democracy is it the truth of
it that you know in some ways it quite
suits the s p to be talking about
independence because it means you're not
talking about your record in Scotland
and what's currently happening in
Scotland I mean let's look at the NHS
for example the worst any waiting times
figures on records 6 000 vacancies in
nursing and Midwifery uh minutes of the
meeting of course of Scotland's NHS
leaders in September saying there's a
billion pound hole in the budget so it's
not possible to continue to run the
range of programs the NHS currently
offers while remaining safe and doing no
harm this is really frightening stuff
it's an absolute priority of the health
secretary and the government to improve
the outcomes in NHS Scotland we know the
responsibility that we've got to do that
right it's not good enough then yes I
admit that that has to be better look I
could say to you if you can trust the
performance of NHS Scotland against
other parts of the United Kingdom then
we outperform other parts of the United
Kingdom however we have to do better I
absolutely accept that but one of the
problems of all of this Sophie you look
at what happened last week with the
Autumn statement the fun something that
we get is largely driven by the
consequence of the UK budget and our
budget in real terms has been cut this
year that's the reality we don't have
the borrowing parts we know that we need
to drive investment into our Public
Services look at what's going to happen
in the UK over the next four years five
years 30 billion pounds of cuts to the
public space it's not just about money
though is it look at these minutes
minutes again everything is a top
priority what is the real Focus it's a
managing issue as well isn't it you know
I can talk about my own health board at
nhsi and then I've got some great people
there that are leading that organization
but we've come through the covert crisis
there's a backlog that we have to
contend with and we should applaud those
are working really hard in our NHS the
other thing of course is that they are
discussing the possibility of a two-tier
Health System let's just rule that out
completely that will not happen where
the wealthy will pay for treatment that
will certainly not happen in Scotland
whether that's in the current status or
in an independent Scotland NHS care will
be free at the point of use for everyone
I'm interested to know your thoughts on
the new UK prime minister Rishi sunak
can you do business with him easier than
Liz Trust
you know we've had a really difficult
period with Boris Johnson and Liz trust
we had no relationship no relationship
with the devolved Administration but
that's as opposition parties I'm looking
forward to having a a normal
relationship where we can work together
and for example I've been asking him for
more support for the tider industry for
example so we can wrap that up of course
I will want to do things whether it's in
order interest to do so work together
over Ukraine stand up against Putin but
he has to recognize democracy uh now
just finally uh World Cup fever
unfortunately of course Scotland didn't
qualify who are you going to be
supporting in the World Cup I'm looking
forward to seeing all the games and I
wish I think importantly I wish Wales in
England all the best and the people here
can celebrate the competition and really
enjoy seeing their teams playing and I
just aggrieve the fact that my country
on this occasion and sadly once again
not there uh talk about celebrating did
you celebrate a little bit when Iran
pick one past England no I didn't
adopted of course not
I wouldn't dream of doing such a thing
thank you very much for being on the
program good to see you thank you